we begin this morning with a white house
under siege as President Trump started a
nine-day for country visit through the
Middle East and Europe the political
turmoil surrounding his presidency is
widening mr. Trump and the first lady
received a red-carpet welcome when they
arrived in Riyadh Saudi Arabia this
morning his first stop but too damaging
reports came out on Friday shortly after
the president left the United States
both are connected to the investigations
into Russian interference in the u.s.
presidential election major Garrett is
traveling with the president in Saudi
Arabia but we'll start with Errol
Barnett in our Washington bureau who has
the latest on the controversies clouding
this White House
Errol good morning good morning there
seems to be a steady stream of damaging
leaks coming from sources inside the
White House and elsewhere in government
concerning the Russia investigations
also late Friday we learned former FBI
director James Comey will testify before
the Senate Intelligence Committee in his
first official public appearance since
his firing questions over the
president's actions persist despite mr.
Trump wanting to move on President Trump
appeared upbeat as he left the White
House alongside First Lady Melania Trump
Friday but simultaneously the New York
Times published comments the president
made while meeting with the Russian
ambassador and foreign minister last
week the day after he fired FBI director
James Comey according to notes of the
meeting read to the Times mr. Trump said
I just fired the head of the FBI he was
crazy a real nutjob also adding I faced
great pressure because of Russia that's
taken off responding to that Senator
Patrick Leahy in a tweet wrote this is
what obstruction looks like the White
House did not dispute the quotes press
secretary Sean Spicer issued this
statement quote by grandstanding and
politicizing the investigation into
Russia's actions James Comey created
unnecessary pressure once again our
national security has been undermined by
the leaking of private and highly
classified conversations I think it
divides the country I think we have a
very divided country because of that in
many
the things during a joint press
conference with Colombia's president
Thursday mr. Trump was asked his
thoughts on Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein appointing former FBI
Director Robert Muller as a special
prosecutor to investigate collusion with
Russia well I respect the move but the
entire thing has been a witch-hunt and
there is no collusion between certainly
myself and my campaign but I can always
speak for myself and the Russians zero
Rosenstein who the White House initially
cited as establishing the basis for
Combes firing briefed the House and
Senate on his decision to appoint Muller
as a special counsel Democratic Senator
Claire McCaskill he did acknowledge that
he learned Comey would be removed prior
to him writing his memo also emerging
Friday is a report from The Washington
Post on the FBI investigation
it says the agency has identified a
current White House official as a
significant person of interest the White
House responded quote a thorough
investigation will confirm that there
was no collusion between the campaign
and any foreign entity Alex
Errol Barnett in our Washington bureau
thanks Errol